I think he deserves a lot worse than the
death penalty
you really tore apart the city we took a
big hit we're doing a great job here I'm
back from it but we're never gonna be
the same so just recharge their life in
prison I don't believe the death
penalty's and I just don't think it's
our job to decide who lives and who dies
I personally do agree with the death
penalty but I'm certainly conflicted
because I think that putting the bomber
to death makes him a martyr personally I
think he should spend the rest of his
life in jail just because if he does get
the death penalty it'll be so many years
of Appeals that families will have to
listen to and go through and I don't
think he's worth the time of day to
listen to if he does have a conscience
if any I think life imprisonment would
be the better option like his conscience
will eat at him like every day